alors maintenant pour faire le point
dans le dossier de la fonderie horne on
retrouve claude bélanger qui le chef des
opérations de cuivre en amérique du nord
pour glencore on le retrouve à rouyn
noranda monsieur bélanger bonsoir oui
bonsoir vous avez présenté votre plan
aujourd'hui pourquoi ces quinze
nanogrammes est ce que ça aurait pu
davantage 10 et même jusqu'à 3 nano
grammes et est ce que ça aurait pu être
plus rapidement également
au quay d'un premier m'a écouté
lorsqu'on va faire c'est qu'on est en
train de transformer la fonderie horne
dans une nouvelle usine dont pour
permettre de réduire les émissions au
maximum dans le délai convoi implanter
ses projets donc on parle de projets
d'investissement de 500 millions $ et ce
qu'on fait aussi en même temps c'est
qu'on met des projets transitoire pour
nous permettre de résurrection en même
temps qu'on travaille sur des projets
majeurs structurants une fois que ces
projets voient une mise en place on sera
en mesure de regarder voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut optimiser davantage
c'est clair que il faut y aller avec
cette étape là aujourd'hui on peut
parler du trader et grands mais c'est
clair que pour nous on est prêt à
mobiliser pleinement engagés pour
continuer à travailler et voir ce qu'on
peut améliorer la performance
environnement est ce que vous travaillez
sur un autre plan justement parallèle
pour arriver à 3 nanogrammes le plus
rapidement possible il a écouté
présentement l'idée c'est vraiment de
mettre en place ce projet là qu'ils
voient à les réduire je dirais et à
siniser la captation des émissions et
une fois le projet sera mise en place
une fois qu'on va commencer à deux
projets en place on va être en mesure de
voir son rôle les opportunités
présentement c'est utile de le faire
parce que y venant autant on va
transformer complètement le fond d'une
nouvelle fonderie convoi est implantée à
l'intérieur des bâtiments que nous avons
et une fois qu'on va remis ses nouveaux
projets de ces nouveaux grands grandes
infrastructures et les nouveaux projets
on sera en mesure de voir comment ce
qu'on peut avant investissements donc
important 500 millions mais vous
demander l'aide du gouvernement soutien
financier du gouvernement du québec pour
financer justement cette transition vous
demandez combien au gouvernement
écoutez on est vraiment dans les
premiers justin ans puisque j'aimerais
mentionner aussi un vous à la population
c'est qu'elle comme les autres
entreprises au québec qui font des
événements majeurs il ya toujours des
discussions avec le gouvernement c'est
ce qu'on est en train de faire on est
aux premières discussions néanmoins nos
équipes sont déjà mobilisés on n'attend
pas le gouvernement pour se lancer il en
si ces projets mais sans un soutien
financier qui serait par exemple
satisfaisant est-ce que la
transformation se ferait quand même
tout à fait nous on est déjà
pleinement engagés nos équipes sont là
travaillent à mettre en place les
projets toute l'organisation a déjà été
mise en place donc absolument donc avec
de l'argent public ou sans argent public
vous fait le travail et en 2027 on sera
15 nanogrammes oui tout à fait je le dis
monsieur bélanger glencore est quand
même une multinationale qui a fait 200
milliards de revenus en 2021 près de 5
milliards de dollars américains de
profit net pourquoi vous avez besoin de
l'aide du gouvernement du québec
écoutez on parle d'un investissement
quand même ici significatif que va
transformer la fonderie d'une manière
importante pour permettre aussi des
émissions mais aussi pour se projeter
vers l'avenir comme vous savez sûrement
la faune du lion est une entreprise
technologique qui vont recycler le
matériel en amérique nord vraiment le
plus important en amérique du nord on
veut continuer à poursuivre dans cette
lancée là et encore une fois comme je
mentionné l comme les autres entreprises
qui font des investissements majeurs on
est toujours institution avec les
couleurs je comprends très bien et je
comprends que toutes les entreprises
sont en discussion avec le gouvernement
mais je réaffirme les chiffres 200
milliards de revenus pour glencore 5
milliards de profits on se demande
pourquoi glencore demande de l'argent
pour quelque chose qui doit être
fondamental c'est à dire une production
responsable et qui n'atteint pas la
santé de la population
c'est votre responsabilité
oui tout à fait et puis on prend nos
responsabilités ce matin on a fait une
annonce importante d'un investissement
important
donc nous on est pleinement engagée à
mettre en place des projets dont on veut
réduire au maximum tous les employés
également y participe donc
comme j'ai dit on a des projets l'obi-1
bien placé pour améliorer nos
performances début du mois d'où il ya eu
un article sur radio canada.ca thomas
gerber thomas deshaies qui disait que la
fonderie avait reçu en cinq ans plus de
trois cent quarante mille tonnes de
déchets industriels dangereux qui
venaient d'un peu partout notamment de
russie de singapour du brésil
la fonderie horne est aussi donc une
usine de recyclage de déchets mondiaux
ultra contaminés qu'est ce que vous
faites pour s'assurer qu'il ya pas des
missions dangereuses pour la population
de ces déchets là
écoutez moi je reste des matériaux
recyclés et malheureusement là demain
dommage la réglementation effet c'est un
produit qui est pour un produit même des
matières présent électronique en chine
vit votre vieux cellulaires verte n'a
pas et considérait comme le déchet
dangereux donc des règlement très strict
au canada on suit ces réglementations là
il n'y a pas d'enjeu à ce niveau là on
fait partie des entreprises il ya pas
dangereux pour la santé de la population
locale avec ses michettes qui viennent
d'ailleurs dans le monde non non c'est
en fonction de la convention de bâle
encore une fois les réglementations sont
très strictes ici au canada c'est suivi
de mai très rigoureuse dans les
opérations il n'y a pas dans un jeu à ce
niveau bien monsieur bélanger merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d
oh